this was hilarious so the start of
episode four for the house of a dragon
brenia was basically doing in-person
tinder as she was looking for a match to
be suitable to be her husband the first
person who came up was a person who was
quite old older than her own father so
obviously she said no to that person but
then the second person who came up was
this young child so he's doing his
pickup lines his speech to try to get
the interest of rhaenyra and then
there's this guy in the crowd who starts
trash talking him indicating that he
obviously won't be a good match for her
because he's a child how can he possibly
look after her the kid eventually
snapped and pulled out his sword and
engaged in a fight with a fellow and
ends up actually winning and killing him
like probably no one in the crowd that
expected the kin to actually win this
fight but he did so served off a guy
right but anyway what did you guys think
of this scene and the episode as a whole
because for me the hassle of dragon just
keeps getting better and better this
episode had like no action in it but had
my attention the whole entire episode
the writing and drama and everything is
just so good so i cannot wait for the
fridge episode but anyway that's about
it for this video so please do consider
subscribing thanks for watching guys